ja nicht mehr lange dann ist es vorbei
mit der kanzlerin und so fing alles an
damals mit angela merkel seitdem sind
5839 tage vergangen habe ich natürlich
nach gezielt 16 jahre kanzlerin doch in
ein paar wochen sie hier
im kanzleramt auch ihr bild auf dann ist
angela merkel als kanzlerin nämlich
geschichte und was macht sie dann als
kanzler rentnerin ja vor ein paar wochen
hat sie darauf diese antwort gegeben
ich möchte schon in der jetzt kommenden
lebensphase mir genau überlegen was
kommt denn in mir so hoch was ich jetzt
machen möchte richtig schreiben möchte
ich reden möchte ich wandern möchte ich
zu hause sein möchte ich in die welt
fahren und dazu habe ich mir vorgenommen
mache ich eben erst mal nichts an bord
dazu kommt
eine kanzlerin die erst mal nix macht
außer ab und zu ein buch lesen von wegen
anscheinend hat angela merkel doch noch
große pläne als rentnerin denn wie bild
heute enthüllt will sie als ex kanzlerin
so viele hochbezahlte mitarbeiter
anstellen wie kein altkanzler vorher und
so sieht sie dann aus die operation
abendsonne
ja so sieht sie aus als
ob in oder sommersonne für solche
ausflüge hat bundeskanzlerin angela
merkel bald ganz viel zeit jetzt
enthüllt bild exklusiv merkel eröffnet
den steuertopf und schenkt sich selbst
acht mitarbeiter in ihrem neuen büro die
teuerste ex kanzlerin aller zeiten
quartiert sich natürlich in bester
berliner lage ein unter den linden aber
den ruhestand will sie nicht mit
irgendwem verbringen sondern unter
freunden genauer gesagt besten
freundinnen der verdacht im politischen
berlin merkel will auf diesen stellen
ihre jahrelangen engsten vertrauten
weiter beschäftigen das wären beate
baumann bisherige büroleiterin der
kanzlerin und redenschreiberin eva
christiansen sie sollen die
gewinnerinnen des üppigen vorhangs
werden und als büroleiterin monatlich
jeweils ein grundgehalt von knapp 10.000
400 euro
10.400 euro kassieren das grundgehalt
des referenten
5670 euro was sie dann zu neunt machen
na ja die erfahrung zeigt nicht nur für
ihre aufgaben abwickeln wie eigentlich
vorgesehen sondern auch lobbyarbeit und
private termine organisieren und wer
soll das ganze bezahlen nattler 4 die
steuerzahler wie bei altkanzler gerhard
schröder top lobbyist von russlands
präsident putin
er machte schon ordentlich ärger ihm
waren damals nur sechs stellen genehmigt
worden laut rechnungshof schon damals
viel zu viel merkel setzt sich jetzt
deutlich über die vorgaben hinweg und
will acht stellen wir sagen der
künftigen kanzlerin ag schon jetzt also
[Musik]
acht mitarbeiter stellen wahnsinn was
sagt eigentlich unser bild chefreporter
peter thiele zu diesem riesigen
mitarbeiterstab
normalerweise sind es fünf also fünf
sind eigentlich noch genehmigungsfähig
sie wollte 98 hat sie jetzt bekommen ist
schon eine ganze latte also natürlich
wird sich auch in der rente noch was zu
tun haben also die altkanzler nicht
beschäftigungslos
aber acht stunden wirklich war schon
mehr als im büro oder sind schon zwei
büros ja also gut also da wird auch noch
jemand einkaufen gehen können
was gibt es noch zu tun ja also es ist
natürlich viel post zu machen klingt
immer blöd aber es ist es tatsächlich
und wir sind ja auch wenn wir alt
kanzler altkanzler haben auch nach
repräsentationspflichten also zum
beispiel können die auch noch als ersatz
für den amtierenden kanzler zu
meinetwegen zu beerdigungen grip
geschickt werde ich habe jetzt mal
erlebt auf kuba als fidel castro
gestorben ist da fliegt man jetzt in so
ein diktator stirbt nicht unbedingt
selber hin sondern da lässt man fliegen
da ist zum beispiel gerhard schröder
hingeschickt von der auch diesen
diktator sehr gut kannte der damals
damit die bundeskammer die
bundeskanzlerin in havanna vertreten das
kommt mit dazu und dann wird sie
natürlich reden halten also staatsmänner
und starts frauen von von ihrer größe
von ihrer weltweiten bedeutung die
kriegen schon ordentlich geld für gut
reden also haben wir so sechs reden im
jahr da hast du dann noch mal zusätzlich
aus gesorgt da muss die rente gar keine
sorgen machen barack obama zum beispiel
kassiert mehr als 100000 euro pro rede
dar und angela merkel nicht ganz
herankommen aber 50 60.000 rede ist dann
auch drin man könnte jetzt argumentieren
sie könnte dann die leute selber zahlen
aber doch die frau war 16 jahre
bundeskanzlerin ja wirklich gerade sagen
und wenn man den vergleich sehen so
gerhard schröder der es als altkanzler
natürlich vor allem als lobbyist ins
gerede gekommen weil er für gazprom und
so weiter nord stream 2
angela merkel kann man sich kaum
vorstellen nach den 16 jahren wo sie
wirklich als als die integre person egal
wie man politisch zu ihr steht auf jeden
fall als die integre person in
deutschland gehandelt hat
das ist ja eine frau die in der welt
etwas zählt die deutschland auch nach
wie vor repräsentieren wird in der welt
ist das nicht ein bisschen kleinlich
wenn man da jetzt über zwei mitarbeitern
oder weniger entspricht das ist der
grund warum ich mich komplett empöre
also ich finde dich 40 angemessen ich
finde acht leute b66
besoldungsgruppe 6 das knapp 10.000 euro
und dann irgendwie auf herz sind doch
alles verdienstvolle mitarbeiter die
hätte man auch woanders unterbringen
können ob es acht sein müssen wagen ich
wirklich zu bezweifeln das ist mir zu
viel aber natürlich die frau war 16
jahre bundeskanzlerin sie seit 31 jahren
sitzt im deutschen bundestag natürlich
hat sie verdienste und sie wird eins
nicht machen sie wird nämlich die ist
nicht eine nummer die gehalte schröder
macht nicht machen gerhard schröder wird
bezahlt vom kreml von rosneft und von
der nord stream ag und hat trotzdem noch
obwohl er diese hohen wirklich hohe
nebeneinkünfte hat oder haupt einkünfte
eigentlich hat obwohl er hat vom kreml
bezahlt wird lässt er sich trotzdem noch
der mitarbeiterstab vom deutschen
steuerzahler bezahlen auch das büro das
wird bei angela merkel wegfallen aber
trotzdem unter dem strich acht leute
sind zu viel wo wird sie leben ich habe
da dieses bild von dieser schicken
altbau villa in hamburg im kopf ja es
seit monaten beschäftigen wir uns damit
herauszufinden wo angela merkel denn
wohne wille hat es gibt unterschiedliche
unterschiedliche angaben ob sie sich
tatsächlich nicht wieder gekauft hat
oder also es gab immer an der elbe in
hamburg in der adresse das ist klar
dementiert worden auf also wirklich aus
dem direkten umfeld
und warten wir mal ab ob es tatsächlich
zum kupfergraben bleibt hier in berlin
direkt gegenüber vom pergamonmuseum und
die kleine hütte die datsche draußen in
brandenburg oben in der uckermark in
ihrer heimat nicht fern von templin
warten wir mal ab
sie ist ja eigentlich sehr bescheiden
ich würde diese einfach villa in hamburg
auch gar nicht so zu ihr passen ist aber
sie gilt als bescheiden und sie hat
einen bescheidenen lebenswandel aber das
schließt nicht aus dass sie erst
vielleicht doch dann im rentenalter noch
ein bisschen krachen lässt und die
wohnung die sie jetzt hat dies auch
nicht so schlecht also ist jetzt nicht
sie wurde nicht in der zweizimmerwohnung
in der allerschlechteste berliner lage
sie guckt auch sie guckt aus pergamon
museum auch die museumsinsel also ja
können wir ihr nehmt den guten ruhestand
hoffen wir dass sie den mit ihrem mann
zusammen schön einträchtig verbringen
kann sie wird in die u-bahn fahren sie
wird wahrscheinlich reisen und zu einer
wieder allein oder zu zweit oder mit
einer guten freundin schauen wir mal da
kann man sich wirklich vorstellen so wie
sie gesagt hat erst mal ein buch lesen
dann einschlafen dabei und dann
überlegen was sie jetzt macht dass sie
gar kein amt mehr wahrnimmt in
irgendeiner form sei es in europa oder
das goethe-institut oder es wäre zu
klein viele fleck lässt sie sachen an
sich heran tragen und dann wird sie
gucken aber ich glaube nicht dass sie
sofort etwas macht also sie wird
tatsächlich irgendwie wollen erst mal
ruhe finden sie muss sich auch dann
wieder in die private rolle rein finden
auch in die rolle der tanja ein dann ja
einfachen ehefrau das ist alles nicht so
fürchterlich einfach und sie wird
tatsächlich muss ich auch gesundheitlich
erstmal wieder erholen wir dürfen nicht
vergessen sie ist noch immer
angeschlagen sind über anderthalb jahren
steht sie bei kaum einem termin es gab
nur einen einzigen termin wo sie zum
stehen gezwungen worden ist weil diese
attacken hatte und davor wirklich angst
hat es gab einen einzigen termin das war
in moskau an der kremlmauer bei einer
kranzniederlegung dieses jahr als
siedler die mutigen quasi gezwungen hat
stehen zu bleiben nachdem sie die
schweigeminute gemacht hat vor dem kranz
hat man die nationalhymne abgespielt und
bei der deutschen nationalhymne kann
sich die kanzlerin nicht bewegen und
nicht umdrehen und ansonsten ist sie
immer noch körperlich angeschlagen sie
ist nicht voll gesund sie wird sich
erholen wollen und sie wird sagen wir
langsam in den in
den alters abend and leiten und die muss
auch erstmal runterkommen ist auch nicht
so einfach es ist kein einfacher job es
ist ein stressiger job und dann fällst
du in ein loch man muss doch mal wieder
rausfinden wie sie wahrscheinlich im
supermarkt in berlin beim einkaufen
danke